[Musique]
moi je dirais que c'est la manier bout
elle avait une voix reconnaissable entre
toutes
cain a fait une remarquable interprète
de nos plus grandes chansons m'ont et
clairac née monique tremblay venait
d'une famille modeste du quartier
rosemont à montréal
elle a commencé à travailler dans une
usine avant de faire ses débuts comme
comédienne à la radio à l'âge de 15 ans
puis elle se dirige vers la chanson elle
se produira au faisan doré
là où l'on découvre une nouvelle
génération d'artistes québécois
francophones à montréal
elle jouera aussi au théâtre à la
télévision et un peu au cinéma
à partir des années 60 elle connaît de
grands succès en interprétant les
chansons des vigneault leclerc léveillé
et des chants
elles m'ont
m
monique leyrac sera la première artiste
de la chanson québécoise à s'illustrer
sur la scène internationale en france en
belgique et au liban en 1965 elle
remporte le grand prix du festival
international de la chanson de sopot en
pologne avec mon pays de gilles
vigneault
célébrant ma chance
[Musique]
puis elle s'associe avec un jeune
parolier luc plamondon dans les années
80 elle produit une série de spectacles
en solo ou sally ses talents de
chanteuse et de comédienne
des spectacles sur les ligands sarah
bernhardt paris berlin et la musique des
années 1900 de véritable tour de force
elle fait aussi un retour au petit écran
comme comédienne dans des dames de coeur
et au théâtre comme dans cette pièce de
michel marc bouchard
le voyage du coup rendement dans les
années 90 elle se retire doucement dans
ses terres en estrie monique leyrac une
innovatrice passionné qui a sans cesse
repoussé ses limites avait reçu en 2013
le clae du québec couronnant toutes ces
années au service de la chanson et des
auteurs compositeurs de chez nous les
gîtes bougies radio canada montréal